hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 1 of on duties the work of stoic
ethics that he lays up Cicero discusses
the virtues and in particular the virtue
of justice one of the subdivisions of
the virtue of justice is what he terms
beneficence and in other places
benevolence this is a disposition of
doing good to other people going beyond
the rules or what's required to do more
than that to help them out to show
generosity now one of the questions that
we can ask is how much under what
conditions and and one of the possible
answers that that some people give is
well you should always give as much as
you possibly can you should always do
you should always help as much as you
possibly can that the more that you do
have that the better a person you are
Cicero doesn't take that position he
does think that we ought to go beyond
just what you know people's rights are
or what the law says or what we've
promised we should do more than that but
we shouldn't go too far and so this
raises a very interesting question why
do we need guidelines about how far we
want to go or who we ought to be
generous orbán if assent with why
shouldn't we just simply say whenever
you see a person in need help them out
whenever anybody could be assisted in
some way by your talents or your money
or your social position use those to
help those people well you know one of
the problems that comes up is we only
have so many resources and some of those
resources are almost impossible to add
to and then we can get more wealth and
we can certainly develop more talents
but you cannot get yourself more time
and although you can train yourself to
pay more attention you can only pay
attention to so many people at any given
time are you depriving others by giving
to those
who you do help are you committing
injustice in that way sister would say
no you're actually being prudent and
you're being just by by doing so we need
guidelines to help us out in these sort
of situations particularly the people
who are most inclined to help other
people out need these guidelines the
most the people who are kind of
standoffish and and stingy and and not
inclined to help people well they they
might need a little reminder - you know
you should do some charity work or some
volunteering or give of yourself help
your neighbor out but the people who are
always giving might go too far so if
this role provides some very important
guidelines here the first up with it
which well let's run through them in
order so they are don't harm the person
or other persons this is the first one
he says the second one is don't go
beyond your means don't go beyond what
you actually have or what you can
sustain proportion your benevolence or
beneficence to the merit of the person
and this actually covers quite a lot as
we'll see show proper gratitude that
that's an obligation as well and then
exercise judgment and consideration when
you are giving don't just give because
it makes you feel good give because it's
actually the right thing to do in this
particular case so let's look at each of
these in turn
he says there's many who transgress this
first one don't harm the person or other
persons because what they do is they
take from one person to give to another
he uses as an example some of the people
in Roman society who are robbing one
person to enrich another they expect to
be thought generous to their friends if
they put them in the way of getting rich
no matter by what means Cicero says this
is beyond the pale this is so remote
from moral duty nothing can be more
opposed to duty so he talks about Sola
and he also talks about Caesar Gaius
sees
how they took things from their rightful
owners to give them to other people
they're not really being generous by
doing that they're being unjust this is
not a form of benevolence even though
those who are benefiting from it are
probably inclined to look at it that way
and to talk about it that way
but if you're harming other people in
the process you're not really being
benevolent you're not being good to
people in general we might also think
about cases where you could in fact be
harming the person with the attention
with the money with the resources with
whatever it is that you're providing
them with for instance if if we think
that we know better than them what it is
that they really need or desire and we
don't take account of that we give them
gifts that are that are unwelcome those
aren't really gifts those are really
obstacles or you might say irritations
what about other cases you know should
we give an alcoholic a drink at the
Christmas party no you shouldn't do that
right should you enable people in other
ways that's not really being good to
them it's not being generous to them so
it's important not to harm other people
by the ways in which we're giving he
also talks about not going beyond our
means this is a very important thing as
well he says those who wish to be more
open handed than circumstances allow of
are guilty of two main faults they're
doing wrong to somebody else they're not
helping they're harming somebody namely
those who are closest to them their
family their friends those who are
dependent about them people who can't
stop giving gifts to random strangers
are going to exhaust their means and not
be able to take care of those people who
they ought to be most closely concerned
with we might say similar things about
the
who have nothing to give to their
community because they've given it all
to some other far distant cause so
there's that says such generosity too
often engenders a passion for plundering
and misappropriating property in order
to supply the means for making large
gifts he says a third thing as well we
may observe that many people do many
things that seem to be inspired more
from a spirit he says of ostentation
than by her heartfelt kindness so there
are some people who want to appear to be
big shots and they go beyond their means
if we do this this is not good for us
and ultimately it's not good for those
who were giving - because you know if
they really do deserve it wouldn't it be
better if we do it in a sustainable way
and this could go not just for money
this could go for other resources like
time you know if you're committing too
much so that you're not actually getting
enough sleep that's a problem
you do need to sleep in order to
function well if you're giving so much
of your we might say emotional energy
that you have none left for yourself
sooner or later you will collapse and
you're not going to be helping anybody
else when they have to take care of you
so that's a real issue this is an
important guideline the third one is
quite complex and we're only going to go
into some of the things that that Cicero
says here about proportioning the the
the beneficence or benevolence - the
merit of the person he says an acts of
kindness we want to weigh with
discrimination the worthiness the value
of the object of our benevolence we
should take into consideration the moral
character of the person we should be
beneficent towards those who are
actually honest rather than to those who
are dishonest we should be beneficent
towards those who themselves will show
generosity or show clemency or mercy to
other people rather than to those who
are hard-hearted irritable antagonistic
this is what Cicero would say it doesn't
mean that we can't show any to those who
are much more disagreeable people who
make other people miserable but it means
that the people who aren't making other
people miserable they should probably
get the first shot at what it is that we
have to give so there there's one aspect
of that he also says we should take into
consideration the attitude of the person
towards us the intimacy of their
relations to us and our common social
ties says all of these you know would be
nice to combine the into one person but
often that's not the case so we may have
somebody who's closer to us by you know
virtue of being our cousin but they're
not a particularly good person and then
we may have a person who's really great
but they're not as close to us which one
should we begin to we want to proportion
it in some way to that he also has a
very important reminder here for us he
says we don't want to set the standard
so high that nobody can meet them he
says there's a beautiful line the people
we live with are not perfect and ideally
wise but we would do very well if there
were found in that Buffy as he says
semblance of virtue the simulacra of
their touches so he says nobody's to be
entirely neglected who shows any trace
of virtue we don't have to have people
who are perfectly virtuous for us to be
you know doing the right thing and
helping them out if we see a tendency
towards it let's help them if we can and
those who are more willing to do that
those people do deserve our beneficence
our benevolence more than those who say
screw it I'm not going to have anything
to do with that one of the other things
that he does talk about that I think is
quite interesting is about gratitude he
says there are those who have already
shown beneficence our benevolence
us those people have a higher claim on
our beneficence our benevolence if
somebody's already given us a gift we
should try to repay that gift if
somebody has opened up opportunities for
us we should try to recompense them in
some way probably we're not gonna have
the same kind of opportunities
especially if it's a a symmetrical
relationship you know somebody like a
mentor for example we might think about
this by paying it forward as people say
you know it may be impossible to do do
you know entire gratitude or something
entirely just towards that person but we
may act that way to somebody else as an
object of our own beneficence the Cicero
thinks that that's a very important
criterion as well
the last point very interesting is that
he says that we should exercise judgment
and consideration we shouldn't be acting
impulsively we should be acting with a
clear mind doing things because there's
the right thing to do not just because
they make us feel good not just because
it touches in our heartstrings as he
says people often do favors impulsively
for everyone without discrimination and
he calls this a morbid type of
benevolence it's not really benevolence
or beneficence it's really something not
good for them and it's probably going to
violate some of these things going the
other means harming the person not
taking account of you know who the
person is perhaps not repaying
benefactors who have helped us out
instead he says we should exercise
judgment deliberation mature
consideration so these are some really
helpful guidelines I think when we get
into the sticky situations because we're
always going to be faced with questions
of well should I give to this person in
this way or give to this person in this
way because I can't actually do it all
or if I give to these two
I can't help out these people over here
some people beat themselves up over this
sister I would say so long as you're
following these guidelines you can
actually tell yourself quite truthfully
that you are in fact a just and
beneficent or a benevolent person
you